read it run from it
the end is near
we're gonna need some help how you been
buck not bad for the end of the world
[Music]
David don't fight for one
we fight for all of them
Avengers infinity war we're going to
open what conduct to the rest of the
world this is not what I imagined you
imagine the Olympics maybe even a
Starbucks everywhere April 27 hey
everybody its charlie Marvel heard that
I wasn't planning on doing an infinity
war video today so that like you know
what we're gonna drop a trailer and
we're gonna show you the Thanos has the
soul stone so I'll explain what's going
on because there are a couple of
different shots in different versions of
the trailer they just released the one
that I added to the beginning of this is
the standard aspect ratio but they
released those awful awful looking
square ones on some social media
platforms like Instagram Twitter and
Facebook turns out when you watch those
versions you get slightly different
footage because the frame has been
extended down so you don't get those
black bars cutting off Thanos his hands
so you can actually see that he has at
least four of the gems in the gauntlet
so of course there's a new round of that
Infinity Gauntlet giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on the video the big
thing here like you can't see if he has
the time gem in his thumb you actually
do need the two different versions of
the trailer to see where he is when he's
walking out of this portal that he makes
using the space stone so first things
first if you didn't know when he's
walking through this cloud portal
looking area that's him using the power
of the space stone to just teleport
wherever he wants to go so far and all
the trailers that we've gotten we've
only seen him port to Titan when they
have that big fight with dr. strange
Iron Man in the guardians of the galaxy
but obviously we know he comes to
Wakanda because we've seen all those
shots of him coming up against Captain
America and him trying to hold the
gauntlet at bay like he's coming for
vision to take the mine stone so this is
a really crazy moment but it's also kind
of funny because you see Captain
America's two tiny little hands grabbed
around Thanos his fist that's how big
his sausages are Captain America's one
hand is only big enough to wrap around
one of Thanos finger so he's got both of
them on two different sides of his
gauntlet here but you only see two gems
in that gauntlet just carefully editing
some cg scenes to make you think one
thing is happening in a scene when
really it completely changes the context
if he walks into Wakanda with at least
four or even five of the gems if he's
he taken the time stone by the time he
comes to Wakanda there's a whole bunch
of other brand-new shots that we get in
this too
more shots of the battle a shot of Shuri
looking unless she's trying to fight
someone off inside her lab like she's
probably got vision in there then they
bail then you get these scenes that
we've seen before where he's off in
these trees you see Captain America try
to stop danos and it's like all right
time to put the last gem in the gauntlet
because think about it this way what
would be the most effective last gem for
him to collect vision because they've
been trying to save him for the entire
film so it makes sense that even though
they're probably more important gems
like the soul gem is the one that we've
been talking about this whole time
where's the final one we'd never seen it
before what does it look like who holds
it right now from an emotional
standpoint they said that part of the
way they get you to care about this
Pokemon journey that Danis is on trying
to collect all the gems is that they tie
that to vision and scarlet witch's
emotional art if we haven't really got
enough footage to connect those dots but
like if you understand what their
relationship in the comics was you can
kind of see how they're gonna lean on
that for the movie and you've gotten a
couple shots of Scarlet Witch looking
like she's getting ready to lose her
[ __ ] but I have a feeling that they're
gonna save a lot of that for the actual
movie so you just have to like piece
that together through the trailers that
we see so if you're not a big comic book
fan vision and Scarlet Witch fall in
love is this really tragic doomed lover
story where like they can't really be
together they can't actually have
children because vision is an Android he
doesn't have those biological parts even
though he's like data he has full
functionality but he can't literally
have a baby there was this big saga in
the comics where she had babies that
were technically just shards of misto
she ended up losing her mind you got to
the end a no more mutants but obviously
they're not gonna be going that far with
infinity war because they're not gonna
be doing any x-men stuff but the whole
idea is is that as tragic it's doomed
it's not going to work out because
Thanos needs to take the gem something
horrible is gonna happen to vision we
don't know what he's going to be like
when we get to Avengers 4 but because he
can self repair I think that we'll see a
version of him carry on even though
we'll also get the pleasure or the
horror depending on how you look at it
of seeing him ripped apart but the thing
about this is that if he has the soul
gem when he comes to Wakanda does he
actually bind it somewhere on
because all the footage that we've seen
so far makes it seem like he only has
two gems when he's fighting the Avengers
on Titan and Doctor Strange still has
the time gem to me that he also might
take the time gem while they're there
I've done a couple videos about
fantasies backstory they've cut most of
it for the film like a lot of people
wondered if there was gonna be a pre
credit sequence or something like that
the Russo brothers have essentially said
that there is no big super duper
flashback for Thanos that are gonna tell
you exactly how he got to where he was
this it they're like that's not enough
time
it's a two-and-a-half-hour movie so what
will happen is is when we get closer to
the movie just depending on the other
trailer footage that they drop we can do
a version of that in a video so I'll
explain his backstory for the movies
don't worry about that they've already
explained a little bit about how they
changed it from the comics so if you
have read Thanos rising in the comics
that's not going to be his movie
backstory but really the purpose of this
trailer is to highlight Wakanda more
like you get a couple different shots as
they cut that chant into it it's just
them chanting just going crazy so that's
gonna be one of the best parts of the
film and I mean we've been talking about
how the Battle of Wakanda is essentially
the climax of the film anyway but we get
to see everybody arrive Captain America
greets Bucky he's wearing his Avengers
costume with his vibranium new arm it's
actually a very classic Captain America
looking costume - people are like wow
that really looks like something from
the 1940s they really want you to think
that he might become Captain America
someday most of you have probably seen
black panther by now this is mbaku so he
is officially on Team black panther at
this point they sort of come to terms at
the end of that movie anyway so I think
he's just happy to have some fun I'm
sure they'll give him some crazy
one-liner because that was one of the
biggest lapse in my theater I'll feed
you to my children just kidding we're
vegetarians the cool thing about this
dress that sure he's wearing too is that
it's a very black panther esque remember
eventually she ascended to the throne in
the comics and became the next black
panther if you guys didn't know in the
lineage of Wakanda there have been
female Black Panthers before this battle
on Titan with all this energy crackling
behind Thanos looks like it's coming
from Doctor Strange but I just love how
he's jumping super high over this like
getting ready to punch someone in the
face I think this is the same thing as
that shot that we've seen in these other
trailers
it just has more finished CG that's the
crazy thing like when we get closer to
the movie we can look at those original
teasers that they dropped and see what
the difference is because they have a
bunch of different special-effects
houses all working simultaneously right
up until the last day so even though
you'll see some of the same footage in
the theaters it will look vastly
different because they'll have spent so
much more time working on the scenes
just polishing it up better high-res
shot of the hook on what looks like the
Asgardian ship really early in the film
bigger shot of everybody charging the
field black panther at the front this is
actually different from the Captain
America shot so I'm interested to see
where these two shots fall like is the
Captain America one much later in the
film or did they just completely change
this because this looks like the
beginning of the battle because black
panther is obviously going to be leading
the army of Wakanda is the king of
Wakanda of course he's gonna be the
first one to charge the field but the
background is completely different from
this other shot so I'm guessing that
this is just much later in the battle
better footage of Iron Man really early
in the film fighting the black order
when they come for the time gem in New
York City at the sanctum new shot of
Scarlet Witch using her power in this
big area of effect way the same way she
did during age of Ultron when she sort
of lost it probably taking down a whole
bunch of these outriders at the same
time then they kind of balance it out
with a couple of jokes from a coy way
like they don't want you to crap your
pants too much when you said you wanted
to open the borders of Wakanda this is
what I imagined what would you imagine
the Olympics a Starbucks maybe the funny
thing about the Black Panther movie is
the way they work pop-culture jokes like
this into the end of that when you said
you had something cool to show me in
California I thought you were gonna take
me to Coachella or maybe Disneyland so
let me know in the comments Thanos walks
into Wakanda with the soul gem in the
gauntlet do you think he also has the
time gem in the thumb and we just can't
see it
what'll happen next is I have some new
Dragon Ball super to post that'll be up
later today but congratulations to the
latest giveaway winner M Shafiq please
private message me so I can get your
contact details there'll be a new round
when I post new Marvel click here for
that brand new spider-man infinity war
scene the Tom Holland just posted and
click here for brand new Game of Thrones
thank you so much for watching everybody
awesome I'll see you guys tonight